In the lead-up to the release of Justice League,
the central mystery for savvy fans wasn't
"is Superman going to be in this thing?" but
rather "black suit—yes or no?"
Prior to November, many would have hedged
toward "yes", considering tie-in merchandise
hyping up the suit, and an Instagram post
from Henry Cavill that many took to be a close-up
of the black outfit.
But when the movie hit theaters with a relatively
lean two-hour runtime, the black suit was
nowhere to be found.
As such, viewers expecting the black suit
were left feeling gaslighted, wondering if
they had imagined the whole thing.
Was this really advertised?
Maybe that was a Henry Cavill fan account.
Now, thanks to cinematographer Fabian Wagner,
it's finally been confirmed that the suit
did exist, scenes were shot, and they didn't
end up in the final edit.
Wagner is fairly clear about this in an interview
with Inverse, responding to a question regarding
whether or not scenes were shot involving
the black suit:
“There were [scenes shot].
It’s a cool looking costume.
Sadly, we didn’t see that either in the
final cut.”
Could the black suit casualty have been the
result of Warner Bros. wanting to distance
the movie from the aggressively dark tone
of Man of Steel and Batman v Superman?
It would make a lot of sense, considering
what we know now about the movie's troubled
production.
Fabian didn't explain what role the black
suit would have played in the film, but the
comics have seen the Man of Steel sport darker
duds on several occasions.
The most relevant occurrence happened in The
Reign of the Supermen story arc, in which
Clark returns from the grave with a black
suit and long hair, after the Death of Superman
arc.
Where he, you know, dies.
Fighting Doomsday.
Sound familiar?
Ultimately, Superman's black suit ended up
on the cutting room floor alongside Willem
Dafoe's appearance as Vulko, most of Robin
Wright's spoken lines, and Cyborg's backstory.
Just another thing to wish for in that director's
cut.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!